Sam bankman freed arrested in the
Bahamas I am astounded that it took this
long they were apparently Democrats were
like well we're not going to go after
him we're not it's like okay we get it
he gave you money unbelievable
unbelievable Martin shkreli said that it
could take them up to five years to
prosecute so he was like a couple days
ago I think on his YouTube channel was
saying it's not that big of a deal they
took four four years and nine months to
go after him is what he was saying but
uh then the next thing I saw is he's
arrested how long did it take him to go
after Bernie Madoff good question right
away so as soon as they found out but he
was doing that how long was he doing
exactly but but we found out about this
scam a while they had a chance to lawyer
up they had a chance to destroy evidence
they had a chance to cover up their
tracks They had a chance they lured up
with Elaine Maxwell's lawyers okay yeah
so they have some of the most powerful
attorneys in the world right now working
with them as they had an advantage to be
able to do a lot of crazy stuff that
they could have hidden so much